FOR A DEBATE FOR DR. OZ.
YOU SAID CANDIDATES SHOULD DO 3
DEBATES.
HERE'S SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
A DARK BUSINESS YOU CHOSE TO BE
IN.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
I KNOW THE GLOVES ARE OFF
AGAINST HERSCHEL WALKER.
HE DENIED THE ALLEGATION ABOUT
ABORTION.
THERE IS ANOTHER CONTROVERSY
WITH WARNOCK'S CHURCH AND TAKING
PEOPLE OUT OF HOUSING AND
HERSCHEL WALKER OFFERED TO PAY
BACK RENT FOR THOSE PEOPLE.
YOU ONLY SEE ATTACKS ON HERSCHEL
WALKER?
>> BECAUSE THE ROAD TO THE
MID-TERMS RUNS THROUGH GEORGIA.
I DIDN'T KNOW THIS ABOUT
WARNOCK.
I JUST HEARD IT TONIGHT.
I BET NOBODY IN GRGE KNOWS IT.
IF YOU ARE WAITING ON THE MEDIA
TO TELL YOU WHAT IS GOING ON IN
GEORGIA -- OTHER THAN DESTROYING
HERSCHEL WALKER'S WALK, YOU WILL
WAIT A LONG TIME.
REMEMBER KAVANAUGH?
THEY CAME UP WITH SOME LETTER.
TAKE HIM BLIND SIDE WITH
ALLEGATIONS TRYING TO DRIVE HIM
OUT.
HE STOOD IN THERE.
HERSCHEL WALKER WILL STAND IN
FROM TOO.
THIS NEEDS TO BE TURNED INTO AN
AD.
WARNOCK RAISED 90 BILLION
DOLLARS AND HERSCHEL WALKER $30
MILLION.
EVERY LIBERAL IS ALL IN TO MAKE
SURE WARNOCK WINS IN GEORGIA.
WE NEED TO BE ALL IN FOR
HERSCHEL WALKER.
LET'S RAISE MONEY TO TAKE WHAT
YOU SAID AND TELL GEORGIA ABOUT
WARNOCK.
>> Sean: I DIDN'T KNOW THAT
A DOMESTIC DISPUTE SOMEONE CAN
MAKE AN ALLEGATION THE SPOUSE
TRIED TO RUN YOU OVER WITH A CAR
AND THAT PERSON DIDN'T GET
ARRESTED.
IF YOU COVER-UP AN INVESTIGATION
INTO CHILD ABUSE AND OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE AND YOU RAN THE CAMP,
HOW COME THE PEOPLE IN GEORGIA
DON'T KNOW THAT?
FOR ALL OF THE STUFF SAID ABOUT
HERSCHEL WALKER, SOME HE SAID IS
NOT TRUE, WHERE IS WARNOCK EVER
BEING ASKED A SINGLE QUESTION
ABOUT ANY OF IT?
>> WELL, HE WILL NEVER BE ASKED.
WE WILL HAVE ONE DEBATE FRIDAY
NIGHT.
I HOPE THIS IS BROUGHT UP.
HERSCHEL WALKER IS BEING OUT
SPENT 3-1.
HE NEEDS TO RUN ADS TALKING
ABOUT WARNOCK VOTING AGAINST
BORDER PATROL AND INCREASING THE
IRS AND TELLING THE PEOPLE IN
GEORGIA THAT WARNOCK SHUT DOWN
DOMESTIC OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
IN THE UNITED STATES.
MAKE US MORE DEPENDENT ON
FOREIGN OIL AND GAS AND TELL THE
STORY ABOUT THE DOUBLE STANDARD
THIS YEAR.
THIS OCTOBER SURPRISE AGAINST
HERSCHEL WALKER, DO YOU THINK
THAT'S AN ACCIDENT?
THEY DROPPED IT RIGHT BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
TO HELP HERSCHEL WALKER AND TO
HELP YOUR OWN FAMILY.
IF YOU LIVE IN GEORGIA, VOTE FOR
HERSCHEL WALKER.
TELL YOUR FRIENDS TO VOTE FOR
HIM.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A FRIEND, GO
MAKE ONE.
IF YOU DON'T LIVE IN GEORGIA YOU
CAN TELL PEOPLE YOU KNOW IN
GEORGIA VOTE FOR HERSCHEL
WALKER.
ALL OF US CAN SEND MONEY TONIGHT
SO HE CAN RUN 2 ADS AND NOT ONE.
>> Sean: WARNOCK'S MONEY IS NOT
COMING FROM INSIDE OF GEORGIA.
>> NONE OF IT!
IT'S COMING FROM THE SAME DAMN
PEOPLE THAT TRIED TO DESTROY ME.
WE WON'T L